we need some notion uh called enclosur
this was the first proposed in Simo 2020
paper this paper study some foreign key
uh joint queries so this is um not the
same class of queries we are interested
in today uh but the notion is is very
interesting there so it considers an
update sequence so each tle here defines
a lifespan
interval okay so for this table
uh t+ is the time step tole T is
inserted and T minus is the time step
this tle will be delet is deleted
okay so what's the enclosur L of this
tle is defined as the maximum number of
disjoint life
spans contained in this left span
Temple left span interval
okay
then what's the enclosure list of the
update
sequence you look at this part this is
the average just the average of the uh
enclosure list of all the toos in update
sequence okay and we we require that it
should be at at the least one
okay uh they show the okay for this uh
first in first out ofd the sequence okay
uh the incos list is just just one it's
very low and they show the result that
for the foreign K AIC query they can be
update it can be updated in lamla s time
for any update sequence with in C Lambda
s so what is s in Lambda
s s is update sequence we give a
specific update sequence yeah so what is
the form of s is it s the time when it
is inserted so twice the number of you
can just inter as the tole and lifespan
interval so so updates you can uh
interpret as okay as the uh insertion or
deletion the time stamp and which tle
for which relation yeah and then we if
we look
at oh uh so for the picture here uh does
every T have zero en Clos exactly yeah
so we just the for the require to be at
the list one and then finally the Big O
is with respect to the entire sequence
yeah inti sequence
yeah what is firm key and C uh sorry
what did you say zero what is zero
there's no uh disjoint lifespan
completely inside this this uh it's
properly contained like its own lifespan
is always contained completely
contained yeah yeah so uh okay next
question is what is is a foreign key
yeah you can read the paper because they
assume yeah uh for primary key table and
uh yeah and a foring key exist in the
Quarry so uh the this is a easy class of
qu because the output size is always
linear yeah so there's not many
challenges in update uh settings but it
still require some uh techniques there
okay um so this first in first out
sequence has a very inclosure list but
the question is is this notion of
inclosure list good enough okay
yeah every update has a Associated yeah
yeah okay question just in the problem
framing um I think this is the first
time we've seen the cost metric B over a
an update sequence right previously it
was per query or per update kinds of
analyses is there any connection between
the average case of the
per update analysis and the what we're
now doing on the whole batch analysis uh
I don't
know so that might be a good question
for group discussion okay so if we just
consider uh this query and we can show
that even end the first in first out of
the sequence it still require rout and
update time and there some okay the omv
conjecture so this means that okay the
first in first out sequence has very low
incursor list and their defination but
it still cannot capture the hardness of
the of uh of the uh of the update for
this query um so I assume that you all
know about the O MV conjecture uh so I
will skip this part and show some idea
why this qu is hard and the first in
first out have the sequence okay so
sorry are you saying that the result is
wrong um no I I just said that their
notion may not be enough to capture the
harness they didn't consider conjunctive
quy they only considered the a foreign K
atic query yeah they didn't say anything
about the so you're seeing that their
result fails if you have anly query
which is not a foreign
yeah I I said that their notion is not
good enough to capture the harness for
conjunctive
ques without forign care yeah but still
a cyclic or not ayli a cyclic actually
we just focus on free Collex query
conjunctive query
yeah so uh if you are familiar with
something with the O MV conjecture so um
the
uh the common approach to show the
reduction is that we we want some
relation to simulate The Matrix so and
then use some uh the other relation to
simulate the vectors uh but the
insertion to this uh to this Matrix will
be insertion only it will insert at the
initial uh point and then the vectors
will be inserted and deleted okay then
you want to do the omv reduction but
here we only have first in first out up
sequence how how to do
that the idea is that we use this R1 and
R5 as the
indicator okay so first we insert some
uh integer like one two into the uh R1
and
R5 what are you trying to what is the
thaty to Pro oh yeah the proof is that
there exist any data structure uh to for
this query for supporting constant delay
numeration requires root and update time
over yeah over first first
sequence the how to encode the omv uh
here so same idea we still want to use
the middle relation R3 to encode The
Matrix
okay and for R2 we use to encode the
vector U and R4 to incode of the vector
v here but we need another indicator
information here yeah so uh in the first
time they're both
one then at this time we can show that Q
is not empty if and only if this is
true then we just delete one from R1 and
R5
okay at this time okay for this time
point we uh for the U2 and the V2 we
further insert the T toos okay to R2 and
R4 separately but this time those toos
have a indicator two here so what does
this mean so all these tles including U1
V1 U2 V2 exist in the database but
there's no corresponding indicator toos
in R1 and R5 so we conceptually deleted
them from the database already because
they won't contribute to
the Joint result
okay at this time Q is not empty if and
only if H this product is is
true so the high level idea is that we
couldn't explicitly delete toos here but
we can use the joint information right
to filter to simulate this
deletion
process any question so that's why you
need the
to yeah
exactly exactly yeah we use the R1 and
R5 to simulate the deletion in R2 and
R4 uh I missed the point of why can't we
delete directly from R2 and R4 because
this is the first in first out
sequence I see yes for example if we
want all the toos exist in M we just
insert them there right we won't delete
them if you want to simulate OU andv we
need to you know insert some toles for u
1 V one and then delete them and then
insert YouTu video but this is not first
in first out anymore yeah and you want
the first in first out sequence
uh like it to show that this is not hard
under the previous uh definition no
previous definition does not say
anything about the conjunctive query I
just want to say the previous notion is
not enough to capture yeah
exactly okay so you can also have some
similar analysis here to show that if we
want constant delay then one has to pay
at least the root and update time
okay so we need more uh complicated
notion of enclosur list by exploring the
qu structure so this notion is called
The Joint Tre based enclosure okay
similar we have update sequence but now
we need a generalizer joint tree and
instead of just the lifespan of the tles
we we we are interested in the effective
lifespan of the joint of the tles in the
joint tree so what does the effective
lifespan so uh suppose this is a tle te
we are
interested there are two effective LIF
spans the first one is that we only
consider the
first deltion of
topos okay from The Descendant node of
this relation okay and this one is is
symetrically defined at this one okay so
for this one we consider this is the
effective lifespan of T and when we
consider
the
we can see the last
insertion of some
topos from The Descendant node of of
this sub yeah so in some sense we just
shrink the lifespan of the of the tle
okay now the joint Tre based enclosure
list for one tle is now defined as the
still the maximum number of joint the
effective LIF spans that are contained
in this one but we only consider toles
from The Descendant node of this
relation the intuition is that only the
uh updates in The Descendant node will
affect change the status of this tle
okay and similarly the enclosure L of
this whole upd the sequence is defined
as the average enclos list of toles in
update
sequence excuse me yeah but this is now
dependent on the particular choice of a
joint tree yes it dep
joint exactly can you compute
efficiently this Lambda
St if you would have to go over all
possible joint trees uh yes so this
definition depends on the joint tree we
just choose one joint tree you will have
the inclosure list of update sequence uh
yeah if you have another joint tree you
may get another inclosure list so the
question is interesting question in
practice is can you have a can you find
the best joint
yeah this is not inv yeah this is not
investigated and yeah we can discuss
yeah how to do that there are some
theistic there but not so very formal
you
know formal proof
there so let's revisit the the example
we just have okay for this query if we
look at the effective lifespan so for
this tle we can see the first decision
so you can imagine there are some Gap
here so the first delion will become uh
so the effective left span will just
degenerate to a very very small interval
there okay so so these are the effective
interval of the of the topos uh and for
this joint Tre all those tles have the
enclosur list as zero but for toos from
R3 for this
R3 the the effective uh left span
disjoint effective left span is
essentially uh linear because you can
just choose all those uh effective life
spans and they are all disjointed yeah
so that's why uh this query and this up
sequence will have enclosure is as large
as root n so this is not just the one by
the previous lotion of enclosure
L I'm confused why um there we don't
have to worry about multiple derivations
sorry I'm confused why we don't need to
think about multiple derivations it
feels like at least from the picture
that if I lose any one uh dependent
Tuple then I know I don't exist
anymore but uh with projection and so on
isn't it possible for me to have many
derivations
and there's like a disjunctive version
of this picture or something that I'm
not
seeing
uh yes
uh I think I I will have a example for
join project okay but for this specific
one we're just interest in full joint
results okay okay that's let let's talk
about this later okay
yeah okay so next question is is this
joint Tri based inculture is good enough
um at least for the algorithm structure
I just presented yeah for any free conx
query the data structure built on a
specific generalizer joint tree can be
updated in lamla St amortizer time over
update sequence with this enclosure list
yeah um at the same time we find one
query such that it requires at least the
lamla update time over update sequence
with inclosure is assumed omv conjecture
I didn't talk about the joint Tri here
because for this a simple query we can
just have uh uh these two uh generaliz
joint Tre um but we we don't know
whether lamla is good enough to capture
uh all the queries so this is still an
interesting question to ask so what
properties what of the update sequence
uh we need to can exactly capture the
harness
okay okay I I will just SK the low for
this is a similar with just okay so
there's some picture I want to show um
so we are interested in constant delay
and we want to ask a data structure that
can be built in linear Pro processing
time and updated in Cant advertised time
uh if we don't have any restriction on
the update sequence then we
know the query can can have such a data
structure if and only if it has a high
to one generaliz a joint Tre or it is K
hierarchal okay but for other queries we
might have some restriction on update
sequence for example if the update
sequence is first in first out we
require that the query has a high to
generaliz Joint tree and you can you can
check good accise you can check that the
enclosure is is is one yeah and if we
want have some result for or free class
query then we need to require that that
update sequence should be insertion only
or delion only yeah so when you have
more restriction on the update sequence
then we can do better yeah but yeah I
know there are some gap between uh those
class of update sequence so this is also
an interesting question to to explore um
I think as an independent interest
question is uh can you have some nice
structure characterization of
conjunctive queries with hide to
generaliz a joint Tre because for the
hard one generalized joint we have a
very nice cure hierarchal property but
how about for yeah queries with high to
generaliz Joint Tre can you see
something about the structure there um
and this also give us some guidance for
practical update sequence yeah just the
question asked if we know some relations
Is uh never updated for example country
those information or if you have some
relation which is frequently updated
such as the order information or some uh
relations is not that frequently updated
uh but can update that sometime for
example the customer information then uh
how to find such a a good General as a
joint Tre to do the yeah to do the
update
um there are some other interesting
question is can we have more fine Gren
analysis of the update sequence uh just
to consider this is this simple example
we have information when all of the
updates are arbitrary all of them are
first in first out all of them insertion
only then more Fant question is if some
updates are arbitrary some are insertion
only can you still determine uh find out
the harness or find the efficient data
structure yeah you can ask a lot of
sorry a lot of combination of the of
those questions but uh yeah I'm not sure
whe this is a good way to ask question
in this way but you can just Define the
F gr analysis yeah if you for your
interest um now I will talk some uh
lower bounds so these are the existing
results for uh NRE conect query over
insertion only update sequence and also
um uh non hierarchal over arbitary
update sequence so we are still missing
the part for conductive queries without
hi tree uh how to generalize The Joint
tree uh we already showed this in our
previous example and this is another
example we couldn't do it uh efficiently
this with projection here okay
yeah uh uh natural question is are this
two can we extend the harness result to
all conjunctive query with uh for conct
conjunctive queries without a heniz
joint
Tre um I have some okay also the it's a
similar we use the indicator okay to
simulate the deletion
yeah um okay uh I think I will I won't
have enough time to uh cover the part
with aggregations so this is also very
nice nice work uh by the dynamic yamakas
algorithm
um so I think I won't go through the
algorithms here um the only thing I want
to share with you is something like how
does the aggregation increase the
harness okay previously we consider that
uh if we have insertion only update
sequence then all the freeass query can
be handled efficiently but if we
with aggregations some
CES cannot achieve we cannot achieve a
very efficient data
structure uh for example this very
simple query it is free Collex but with
aggregations we need rout update at
lower bound rout update time and also
for this quy yeah um for arbitrary
agregation or mean uh versus Su there
should be a different
uh I think the lower bound we only
require the The annotation to be just
one just to do a sum and yes it's count
yeah exactly it's already hard yeah uh
the proof is is is quite uh interesting
so in the previous one we used the uh
join condition to simulate deletion but
here we use aggregation to simulate dele
okay let me show some
I
Al I don't know uh okay uh do I have
time to do that so you have technically
until roughly 11 oh yeah yeah I think I
will upload the slides to to SL and
there are many animations there I think
just talk offline yeah about the the
algorithm
uh so how to use the aggregation to
simulate deltion here we still want to
simulate the omv conjecture um we use
the R1 to encode The Matrix
okay we also is use the R2 to in encode
the vectors here and we uh let the J as
the result Vector for this query and we
know uh mv1 I is one if W1 I is greater
than zero
okay then
we encode the uh the V2 uh by by R2
again but now we use their
difference to
simulate the result of M
V2 okay so we don't have any deletion
there but we can use the difference
between the aggregation to to see the
difference uh to to see the result of
mv2
okay so the similarly we have a okay we
have a only have a booing query this is
also hard and insertion only update
sequence with if we just want to count
okay no count here just want to detect
whether
exist a result not and similarly we use
the omv
and here again we we use the aggregation
to to uh to simulate the D the insertion
here when you say aggregation uh do you
need like a specific semi ring to do
this simulation for no we just have the
you just
count like this is the sing of natural
numbers natural numbers yeah
I so I I will stop here and with a few
interesting questions so uh is the joint
Tre based inculture is good enough and
um for if it's good yeah how how about
the incos list for aggregations and how
to handle more complicated update
sequence which is not the first in first
out have some other pattern of
properties and how to adaptly find a
good General as joint when you have more
information about update sequence and
how to support more General queries and
I I think OFA have done some work for C
joins and another one is how to do batch
update because we only talk about single
update okay in in in the talk uh when
you have B batch update so what's the
whole picture yeah at last is with self
joints how the lower bound will yeah
will will change
yeah okay so I will stop here and I hope
we'll give you some idea uh for the
discussion yeah thank
you
I think we can take a little break like
15 minutes or so and come back at 11 for
the last discussion of this
Workshop